- 1978, Carmine Galante
goes back to prison
for violating parole.
They should have held
him there, clearly,
because he was consorting
with criminal associates,
violating parole.
But Roy Cohn got him out
of prison in record time.
- So he got let out early '79.
How that happened, I don't know.
- He became very cocky and--
amazingly, he goes on 60 Minutes
and his lawyer, Roy Cohn,
gets to interview
him and present
this simple Italian
man who likes only
to be growing tomato vines.
- I'm going to the country.
- Good.
What are you going to do
when you get to the country?
- Well, I mean, I planted
peppers last week.
Now I'm going to plant tomatoes.
- And this completely phony
picture of this mob boss
is ludicrous.
- You think that had an
influence on the federal judge
when he held that you were
right and the parole commission
was wrong?
- I think so.
I think so.
- He thinks a farmer ought
to be able to seed, right?
- I think so.
I mean, it's very well
known that that's what I do.
- When he made those stupid
moves on 60 Minutes, act
like an old man, it don't work.
You don't fool nobody, man.
Forget about your toma --
tomatoes, wear an old hat,
ripped sweater.
You can't do this.
You can't go public.
Don't work that way.
You don't-- you don't
supposed to do that.
- He had his own rules, his
own ways of doing things.
He was earning money.
He was also skimming money.
But the Mafia operates
to make money,
and in order to make money,
you have to follow the rules.
If you don't abide by the
rules, there are repercussions.
[music playing]
[rumbling subway train]
- July 12, 1979 was a
very hot day in New York,
and a Cadillac was rumbling
its way down streets
of Bushwick, Brooklyn.
There was a lot of
street life going on.
It was a typical
day in Bushwick.
This Cadillac makes its way
down Knickerbocker Avenue
and stops outside Joe and Mary
Italian-American restaurant,
run by cousins of
Carmine Galante.
And Galante, who was
well known there,
made his way to the back.
And there was a backyard garden.
The bodyguards he had
taken with him that day
were Cesare Bonventre
and Baldo Amato.
And the mood was set for
a relaxing afternoon.
[music playing]
[car door slams]
[footsteps]
[gunshots]
[police dispatch]
- I was in an unmarked
police car by myself
and I happened to be
just a couple of blocks
away from Knickerbocker Avenue
when I hear this job come over.
[police dispatch]
- Early before 3
o'clock this afternoon,
blue Chevy pulled up
here in front of Joe
and Mary's restaurant.
Three men got out
wearing ski masks, armed.
Shotguns.
Automatic weapons.
- And as I get there I
run into the backyard.
I'm the first detective there.
There was maybe three cops.
I see the dead bodies.
- There are multiple
gunshot and shotgun wounds.
- As a result of those wounds,
would you say the death was
instantaneous on both parts?
- It would appear that
the death was very rapid.
[dramatic music]
- OK, let's go.
Get outta the way.
[dramatic music]
- My mother called me
screaming, "they killed him.
They killed him.
They killed him."
My mother was destroyed
she was just destroyed,
'cause she loved him.
She never stopped loving him.
She loved this man.
It amazed me, but it was true.
[sad music]
- It was almost surreal,
the whole thing.
I don't think he thought
he would ever die.
He's got that God complex.
He just didn't think
anything could ever--
ever happen to him.
I was very surprised he
wasn't killed much sooner.
And that's probably why I
was so shocked when he died,
because now you don't expect
it anymore because it didn't
happen for such a long time.
Then there was the
wake, which was a joke.
It was a zoo--
reporters, ba-ba-ba-ba.
- For the FBI it was a big
mystery-- why he was hit,
who was the killer--
that had to be pieced together.
- There was no love lost.
When he passed away, there
was 40 people at his funeral.
There's a reason for that.
Nobody liked him.
[music playing]